they're recording is now started so now
we all right
alright there we go oh yeah you wanna
intro it yeah
welcome back to the iced coffee hour
with your host Graham and Jack welcome
back and what is this the six we're both
hosting each other exactly so welcome to
the iced coffee hour this is what the
six episode excel or is it the seventh
yeah this is Saturn at six well they all
blend together after my exact thing but
really quick we should address it we
should talk about what we're what we
elephant in the room all of this new
gear that we have
thanks to road they sent us all this
stuff they were really great about it
because they didn't even ask for like a
shout out or anything like they they
said typically we just asked for this
but like you can do whatever you want
yeah so like this is honestly like it's
sincere thank you to road for doing this
it's incredible we just like this is our
first video ever filming with this so
it'll be cool to look back at this years
from now and like be like a little
started here so yeah Road thank you so
much for anyone who's thinking about
like mic equipment or audio equipment so
far this has been the best so far like
this is this is the fancy stuff that
like I'm like I'm blown away at it so
far yeah way better than all this stuff
we've tried otherwise and also for those
of you who are curious these are nt1
mics and this is the road caster Pro and
this is just like a sound / like mixing
board I don't know I'm not really that
much of an audio guy but it's got some
cool features so thanks to Road yeah
anyway oh and then I also have a
question if you guys prefer me having
the stand and not having the stand if
the pop like is really bad just let me
know because I prefer to have it like
held in my hand but if you guys all
think it's like way better like that
just let me know so what does the pop
dude Z this is a pop filter right so is
that the pop filter basically means that
like you have if you put it on it should
dampen like when you go Pete when you
make him
no no when you go view when you make a
piece sound it like it like yeah it kind
of sounds like a sonic boom kind of like
if you don't have one on yeah really
like like not like a sonic boom sonic
yeah yeah exaggerating a little bit
there sonic boom so so yeah I mean I
don't think it I'm doing a P it's just a
sonic boom everywhere for those of you
guys you're curious
thank you so much by the way for
thousand subs and we've made 677 dollars
and 63 cents you don't we should do an
update every week yeah like here's how
much we've made so far exactly was it
six hundred and seven dollars this month
and we've done four monetized episode
four monetize deficits that's right
mm-hmm
but also like we're still making money
from the first two episodes that's true
Dez yeah yeah so and who for those of
you guys for curious the video with
Jeremy did two hundred and eighty four
dollars video with Christine 162 on our
third biggest video was telling how much
money this podcast match was made ninety
two dollars I love that I love that's my
favorite thing is you explain how much
money you make and that makes money and
then what you do is you explain how much
money you make telling people how much
money you make that's my favorite so I
think we should every episode can be how
much money the podcast is made this week
yeah I'm totally about it yeah they're
just title the video that oh yeah and
just connecting every week that's smart
we just totally reformat the podcast I
just put like EP 7 EP exactly like how
much money it makes so uh we we can't
hear this but I know that this sound you
guys are gonna be able to hear that and
that just made a money sound nice so we
can't use we're not wearing headphones
but you guys can hear it that's cool so
so yeah I just want to know how this
podcast has performed like has it
performed to your expectations or
anything how do you think it's doing
compared to like how you thought oh man
I mean it's tough because ideally for a
channel like this I would want there to
be daily content it's it's tough for me
to only post once a week I don't like it
I'll be honest I know with the podcast
format like that you have to do that
we're doing longer episodes so instead
of you know 10 minutes four times a week
it's just one 40-minute episode I still
prefer the posting daily it's tough it's
tough to see one big spike and then it
just you know settles down and it goes
up again so yeah I can throw up like a
screenshot of our analytic sheet like
right now just so you guys can see every
single Sunday we just make like you know
a decent amount more money than all the
other days the week's not even about the
money so you spike watch time use one
time
and then Monday is usually ok Tuesday's
like man Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday it's to suffer and I'm sitting
there be like no we need to poster get
that and get that back up again so you
know I don't know dude but otherwise
it's been fun it's just it's an
interesting progression where I'm I'm
used to take and control me like no
we're just posting more videos now and
for those of you guys who are asking
because you guys have been talking about
this a lot I don't think that we can do
more than one episode per week now at
least like as it is right now it just
takes up a lot of time to edit these
videos like I mean I've spent like the
Jeremie video took like 20 hours after
recording it there was just audio issues
everything so it's really difficult to
fit another episode in the week but
right now right now one episode of we
yeah yeah thank you guys again so much
for all the support and everything I
would also like I'd like to do something
to show my appreciation if there's like
if you guys want to comment something or
like any video suggestion or something
that that we could lay the road yeah
like a leg review like we'd be super
happy to do that on the podcast so what
if there's like a top comment saying
that you know you want something
different in the podcast or you want
things to stay the same you know we'd be
willing to like I mean I don't know
about you like I definitely would be
willing to go out of my way to to do I
think you would too to have of course do
whatever we can or anything you guys
would like to see any special footage
definitely so let's catch up a little
bit we got to meet LOF obviously you
guys saw on the last podcast episode
which is crazy and yeah I know you were
a big fan I'm a huge fan of his and it's
really funny because he totally is light
amperes he's the same exact person as he
is in his video he's a youtuber for
those of you guys who missed the episode
he's exactly the same in person as he is
on YouTube yes which is just I mean it
was great to like see that he's the same
person loved his laughs yes laughs is
great he's so laid back so yeah he makes
you wanna relax exactly could be the
most uptight person but you hang out
with him and you're just you're calm if
anyone should create ASMR videos it
should definitely be loft oh wow you're
gonna give him ideas that could be his
new like huge hit channel yeah totally I
mean like it was funny during the
podcast I I kept on saying like how are
you sure it's like scooted up close
enough to him cuz he was kind of
speaking like with the microphone a
little far away from his face I go check
out the audio his audio was like 10
times better than grams
then our audio it's so crystal clear and
like yeah but you were the big fan I
mean you were the one it was like he was
fangirling yeah I was her leaf and I was
getting all giddy and why why ain't you
why and rails mile off because I I just
I liked his style and I know for a fact
all of his pranks were real and his
personality is so it was so attractive
to me like not it was it was it was a
good it's a great personality I just
think he's a he's a cool guy and I
showed him to my friends I showed it to
my family so they also had some like
it's a childhood stuff
imagine you meeting people that you used
to watch demon Thompson I don't know
it'll be about it like degree but I met
Kenan Thompson I would look he doesn't
even have an Instagram on Fortune's I
wanted to reach out to the guy does not
have an Instagram maybe as a Twitter or
something like that but like he I would
I would I would go crazy if I met Kenan
Thompson Kel Mitchell to I think Cal has
a has an Instagram I wouldn't I would
love to I'll hold on let's see if Kel
Mitchell is gonna respond to your
Instagram DM let's see I would love
let's see this is how we do things here
by the way we just reach out to people
on Instagram oh wow we've got 1.1
million followers on on Instagram what
do I say let's let Steve say hey man
big fan you know come on my podcast so I
said hey man just wanted to say I'm a
huge fan and grew up watching you might
want to do something where you say like
I run a YouTube channel with like two
million plus subscribers just so it
gives them more incentive to expand
YouTube channel with two point one I
gotta go to point 1 1 okay yeah million
subscribers yeah so here's the message I
sent we should just do a whole episode
honestly DMing celebrities yeah that's
super popular right now on YouTube I
would do that yeah let's do that maybe
that that's the next podcast guys to
suggest some people in the comments yeah
actually yeah how about this reach out
uh comment yet comment people in the
just in the description comment people
in the comment people in the comments
yeah they're not gonna come to they're
not gonna hear this is road night but
yeah guys think um yeah we can't hear ya
so anyway so comments um celebrities in
the comments and whoever is the most
liked we're gonna go through and watch
out yeah let me see
I said hey man I run a YouTube channel
with 2.1 1 million subscribers and I
just want to say I'm a huge fan grew up
watching Kenan & Kel as a kid absolutely
we love the opportunity to do a collab
or have you on my podcast
all the best you know what I should do I
should I wanted to send him a picture of
that signed Oh
things like what if I loved that but you
know what if I do that I'm worried it's
like Instagram only shows that like top
little first thing so if I send him a
picture it'll be like has sent you an
image let me try it really quick limit
strike Kenan Thompson Kenan Thompson has
an Instagram yeah and I didn't see it
last 5 min me 20,000 followers so you
you have probably a higher chance
reaching out to this guy he didn't I
thought Keene was huge from maybe just
maybe he just created his Instagram you
know what let me just I'm gonna be lazy
I'm just gonna copy paste it yeah yeah
they won't know know or will they just
watch they talk every day and there's a
joke man guess who this you just Betty
Cooper did Ram Stefan I'm like you know
he's like oh a semi the same thing I'm
not gonna lie like when I saw that
autographed poster I had no idea who it
was
really yeah like I I just know I think
Kenan was the guy in SNL right yeah yeah
just changing the names yeah no I I
gotta put I even got your autograph for
way back in the day
all the best snot sweet little all right
sense that would be amazing man you know
what I should follow Kenan Thompson just
as a show of good give him a follow yeah
and you know what I would have to do Kel
Mitchell too cuz you can't follow one no
you can that's no incoming Kenan & Kel
so yeah meeting laughs was crazy I also
did something I I made my first ever
option trade gosh I told you not to do
it
so he told me not to do it in our
private mentorship group link down below
in the description I was talking with
the guys in the zoom call and one of
them was telling me about selling puts
so I decided to do it and I sold a
put-on ni o strike price $7 for those
guys you know options that's what I did
and yeah I made like 29 dollars off of
700 all investment it was a small
investment obviously I'm not gonna do a
bunch of money in the beginning when I'm
you know doing options trading but I
made some money off of it to graduation
and I remember telling Graham and Graham
was just like oh my god
but I mean you would have made more
money just buying two to shares of Tesla
you would have made Wayne yeah but that
would have required like a two thousand
dollar investment and also invested
$2,000 no invested seven hundred Wow
well you could buy fractional shares you
would have made more money buying a
fractional share in Robin Hood anyway so
I made some money and Graham was just
like oh my god and you know you wouldn't
you win a couple of times a little bit
and then one time you lose and that's it
that's everybody that article we read
it's like that that lady who is she is
she was like you know Robin Hood is like
a fun gambling game yeah it's easy yeah
reminds me it's not easy my situation
like when I had the contract I was so
scared upon the expiration date like the
entire week I was thinking like oh my
god what happens like am I gonna be
losing money am I gonna making money
it's like same thing is going to Vegas
and you know putting your money in black
or red that could be easy money too but
you sit there Lucy's maybe I lose my
money cuz if I made like you know I made
like three four percent in what five
days I want you to do it twenty times
and I want you to make money fifteen out
of those twenty times then I think that
would be a good gauge of how well you're
doing all right
seventy-five percent of the time you
make money I'm gonna continue trading
options and gambling away all the money
I'm getting from the podcast and yeah
and you guys will be able to see the
updates as we go so good you know what
we should do a weekly recap like at the
beginning of every podcast episode one
how much money has the podcast made into
how much money of you may trading up and
how much money have I lost my glute
offsetting all the money we make see
them balancing out like we made $500
this month in the podcast and then I
lost $400 yeah so I'm losing money doing
this but you know so yeah I'll keep you
guys updated and we'll let you guys know
how much the podcast makes we have
totally cool being transparent for those
of you guys who were curious we did not
post on the gram stuff and show on
Tuesday why Graham gosh that pokey man
that pokey pokeyman pokeyman video well
crazy yeah so that's what that I think
is one of the if not the first time on
the on the second channel I purposely
didn't post on a day mm-hmm we had a
video ready yeah we had a video ready oh
yeah
but yeah so what might my theory with
YouTube
is that when you have a video that's
doing so well and it's just getting
pushed out to such a large audience when
you post a new video on YouTube
sometimes YouTube will prioritize that
new video over the one that's doing
really well and I didn't want to
jeopardize that video like cutting down
and theia's because people really
enjoyed it a lot of people are
subscribing from that video and the next
video we have after that just use no
comparison it's like we're going yeah my
response to pokey Maine - I keep my life
savings in cash what do I do
not to downplay the video you guys
definitely should check it out it sits
up right now so you could see the video
I'm talking about but like there's my
response to pokey Maine and then there's
I keep my life savings in cash sitting
in a safe what do you do so that you
know I wanted to purposely wait and just
let that video breathe for a little bit
and then we're gonna do zoom posting and
for those of you guys who do not know
pokey Maine is a person who Twitter
twitch livestreams and she's basically
the female face of twitch and he reacted
to the Jubilee video - I didn't launch
that oh yeah yeah we could do my
response to pokey main part - and just
like have us yeah and just run with it
and I don't want to overplay it but but
yeah basically we posted a video and it
outperformed like basically everything
we've done in a long time on the second
challenge we just liked it that was I
think actually the number one performing
video I've ever had on the second
channel in the first like week yeah ever
by probably double or triple it's crazy
just insane yeah yeah we got to start
responding I think to more people this
come up with like just random people on
youtubes it's just popular people my
response to them to h3h3 it couldn't you
know it doesn't video about you yeah no
nothing him just talking yeah and just
I'm responding to it yeah yeah he's
talking to you but you're just talking
you so offended what's been going on
about this so this is my official
response exactly - and then you insert
whatever popular name here banger videos
yeah miss my response to mr. B's they
reached out to you every oh we got to
talk about that mr. Boehner on the app
finger on the app how far do you go
Graham uh-huh I got 15 minutes maybe 20
minutes and then I realize like I don't
have a chance at winning this and I'm
better off just working I'll tell you my
thoughts afterwards hell
did you go so I went to ours and just
really quickly you basically just have
your finger on an app and see whoever
does it longest gets like a bunch of
money and it was sponsored by mr. beast
so I went for two hours I are they still
going now yes it has someone won yes so
I checked this morning and one of the
guys got like 23 hours into it and the
app glitched oh I saw that yeah Isis I
was the one on trending and then there
was another one I felt so bad for the
guy was watching his you know what I'll
be able to give him a shout-out so at
the very least he didn't he didn't win
but will be it's called saucy together
saucy together saucy together and he's
got fifty five hundred subscribers here
so yeah so saucy together he went all
night and and this morning I was
watching him around like 10 a.m. and he
was still there and he's got like a
either his wife or his girlfriend or
someone with him like really supporting
him and he's been up all night
obviously he's like drained and he's
kept his finger on the app and he's got
no lives left so if his finger goes off
the app he's out and he's sitting there
and you see him like holding the app and
then all of a sudden the Aptus tree
starts out of nowhere yeah it's he
didn't do anything wrong and he was one
of 102 people so he was almost there
yeah this guy got 127 thousand views on
a stream I think that's worth it
yeah for streaming and for a brand new
channel to get five thousand subscribers
overnight it's huge what I should have
done
ideally now that I'm realizing it I
should have live streamed mm-hm I should
have taken it really seriously done it
for charity just you know set up the
cameras whatever and just been there on
my phone I really should have done that
and set up a charger because I started
seeing people doing that and they're
getting you know they were getting
thousands of views that was it and and
no one had like a I was surprised I
thought like bigger channels would be
doing this mm-hmm I didn't see any big
channels that were live-streaming
themselves doing this at all no why you
know I thought my thought was I honestly
felt like I didn't have a chance at
winning this there gonna be people who
are way more motivated than I am to do
this who really needed the money you
know I would have donated it to a
charity or just something like that
but should have done it next year next
next challenge I did I did two hours and
I kind of realized like an hour and I
was like I just I can't do this for you
know cuz it would probably be like 48
hours you know two straight days and I
just I cannot do that right now even if
it is like you know $17,000 it's like if
I get there and I yeah what I'm number
two
like I get second place it's like come
you know what I mean I would know is
livestream your city you you would have
had to monetize it like I had to I had
to I I guy I had stuff I had to do like
I had a video you know I got to edit I
have like a podcast I have to prepare
for and I just I couldn't do all that at
the same time it's just holding my I
think a lot of it's mine a lot of it I
think his mindset I think you really
have to have like believed like I'm
gonna do this at all costs
mmm I'm gonna be up all night I'm gonna
make it happen because that's what it
seemed like the motivation of these
people we're on it
I I think that I definitely had the
confidence yeah like I think that if I
put my I truly think if I put my mind to
it I think I could have I could win it
yeah the thing is it's like I just I
analyzed it from a realistic perspective
you know what I mean and just like it's
not worth it what we should have done is
honestly just live streamed on the iced
coffee hour
set that up and you just do it and you
just live streaming another time yeah
yeah there was another person I think it
was fake I don't know if it was real or
not because these these kids seem kind
of sketchy but they had their phone and
they had like one of those Android
phones with the stylus oh yeah yeah
we're doing it with the stylus pen and
what they would do is to switch hands
they would like you know put it on their
chin and then like do this and like keep
it on there or like just switch hands
around like that yeah they can just do
that instead of using their chin right
well no they were holding it like this
and then and like grabbed it keep it on
but they were trading they were taking
turns so like you know you would see
that one guy holding it and he passed
off to his friend who would just hold it
on there but they never really showed
the screen so it's kind of skeptical if
they were just doing it for views yeah I
think there's so many ways that you
could have cheated that system like I
was thinking you know you get like three
lives what if every life you just like
passed it off to someone that took a
sleep break you know for eight hours
it's just there's so many ways around it
yeah I hope that's the the person that
does window did it like real like
then yeah authentically yeah I know I
don't know because because some of those
things are just so outside the bot like
I would have never thought to use like
one of the stylist I didn't think to use
one of those uh yeah which that would
make it a lot easier cuz your your
thumbs get sweaty after a while yeah my
thumb was it what it was just like
sticking the videos like my LAN comes
right for me so yeah well we'll see you
wins on that I think that would be
really interesting I hope he releases
that video soon upon the top topic of
twitch
would you ever stream on Twitch or would
you ever live stream I'm not a big fan
of live streaming to be honest I mean I
went live on Instagram of you once or
twice and I just didn't like it I don't
like the live a that's scary
yeah I just don't I don't like I don't
like being live I have a lot of respect
for people that go live because you're
like under a microscope and if you get
caught doing any like you know like who
knows what you know something bad can
happen and then all of a sudden you know
but turntables the turntable I don't
know
I'd like I like having to be able to
like it think out what I want to say and
stuff like that even this I mean this is
all unedited but I mean to a certain
degree it's not like people are throwing
questions at me left and right live and
I've you've got got to respond to it
whatever you say is I'm stressful
yeah I'm not a huge fan yeah well yeah
maybe one day maybe one day maybe one
day also for streaming I think the main
source of revenue is uh donations and I
feel like just knowing your personality
it would be weird for you to accept tips
from people I think that you you would
feel weird about it which people like
having their name come up on the screen
now they don't you it would you feel
weird saying like oh thank you for the
three you know $5 tip or whatever no you
wouldn't know cuz anybody because you
didn't really like the idea of a patreon
ah well I guess it's no different than a
patron but I don't know like a patreon
is like a monthly recurring something
you know it doesn't having live I don't
know I feel like if I'm live and someone
wants to willingly you know donate go
ahead it wouldn't have a problem with
that I think it's I think the same thing
but let's see how let me just check out
these sounds
alright one thing that's interesting I
don't know if we can talk about this let
me know if we can so we can stop myself
yes at which is like the main live
streaming platform and then mixer
you know mixer came out so mixer was
Microsoft's version of twitch they came
out with this new live streaming
platform and they paid a couple of
creators like I don't know how much but
I think it's like tens of millions of
dollars like ninja like the biggest
twitch livestream er they paid him to
move from twitch to mixer yeah and they
paid this other guy like ton of money
probably as well to move from twitch to
mixer and then they just shut down like
they were running for a couple of months
they got heard about something and then
they just shut like yeah weird about
this with ninja hosed it yeah wasn't a
ninja they closed down mixer because you
couldn't fight twitch well the thing is
it generally seems that if you have to
pay a creator to go and join it's it's
probably not that good yeah that that's
my initial thought is if it's a good
platform people are just gonna go and
use it like I think tik-tok like maybe
they pay people to go on there I can't
imagine they would it's just it's so big
that eventually people have to go on it
I just can't believe that like Microsoft
lost to twitch you know what I mean it's
like they couldn't provide something
that was do you do you think that
there's going to be competition ever
with YouTube or do you think YouTube's
just way too big because I another way
too big but but it's it I don't think
it's gonna be competition for like in
YouTube format like like tik-tok came
around right and that was so different I
think there's there's gonna be different
competition like that like tick tock I
like I just feel like they're all so
different I don't think anything can
compete with YouTube on a youtube level
in terms of like long-form video content
like this
I don't think so Facebook is tried they
just they do not doing it you know
Instagram tried to Instagram what is it
Instagram TV or whatever whatever was
was terrible it was horrible that failed
but Instagram got really good at the
stories and yeah that's right kind of
develop their own little thing on the
sides not as good not nearly and then
you know tik-tok came out that it's now
its own animal so it's just a different
form of entertainment you think can come
and yeah it would be able to take
YouTube's place but nothing
does what YouTube does no and even
twitch I mean which isn't really good at
streaming then you got YouTube's really
good at long-form video content and then
you know Spotify we could we could say
it's good for free no audio and maybe
maybe they're gonna dominate the podcast
space I don't know but but you're gonna
have different sectors or they're all
gonna dominate in their own their own
space it's interesting because I never
told you this but you know you got an
email from this one
YouTube creator who created their own
platform that's supposed to compete with
YouTube and he got a few creators like
it's like mcjuggernuggets or whatever
and you know boogie2988 those guys yeah
like they are now posting on this whole
different platform that's supposed to be
like competing with YouTube because I
think they they aren't happy with
YouTube's policies or something like
that I didn't respond to it but he
wanted you to to join the the new
platform I mean I'll take a look at it
but it seems like see what I see is a I
like I wanted I want to put my stake
right now in YouTube's loyalty yeah
that's why I didn't yeah I mean they've
obviously they've treated me so well
that at this point it's like I owe a lot
to YouTube so I'm gonna stay loyal to
that yet arresting though but it's so
much money to to run something like that
I can't imagine any like you know
private creator without probably tens of
millions of dollars
it made him uh maybe even you know a
hundred million dollars couldn't compete
with YouTube that's that's my thought I
think it would take probably ten of the
biggest creators to move over like you
would need you know like PewDiePie and
you would need mr. beast and like know
those guys you don't even think because
YouTube also just has like a log of just
like you know fifteen years of videos or
whatever long it's been around you know
of just like golden content yeah it's
it's good it's just gonna be interesting
to see how they switch around what
people want to see and how they
optimized for viewership and where they
lead and what direction that that's what
I think is more interesting is how they
navigate you know the type of content
that they want on the platform mm-hmm
anyways I found that interesting I'll
show you the website after we tactical
also catching up on the week I met Jason
Oppenheim and we went to his house and
his house is incredible
yeah it is like his house is so nice and
it had some of the craziest features he
had a $50,000 TV that rises out of the
ground on hydraulics sick raise $50,000
it's crazy
that's like that's like a fully loaded
like Tesla Model 3 right well it's a
Tesla Model 3 performance basically
that's what is the highest end ya know
anyways he had a crazy TV you guys
should check out that video and also he
had $200 light bulbs I saw these light
bulbs in his house and I was like these
light bulbs look really nice I've never
done that with a light bulb before I'm
not like a light bulb Cronus you were
like I couldn't tell you know a 200 make
you know like picture the light bulb and
I looked at I was like wow this is super
nice I should like try to look these up
maybe get a couple for myself I look it
up it's called buster and punch or
something like that
$200 for the bulb that's it just the
bulb to fancy for me I mean what I got
here is like a seven dollar light bulb
and that for me it was like wow seven
dollars right yeah this should be land
this is like your centerpiece - it
doesn't get centerpiece light bulb
that's all it's one of those like Edison
bulbs yessum box but like what $200 it
was 210 actually her bulb and they're
beautiful bulbs you'll see yeah but so
it's so well it's 230 with tax and
everything's yeah exactly hosh yeah just
absolutely everyday magic dropping it
and you try to be all like gentle
literally holding like two $100 bills in
your hand when you're holding yeah that
and you're burning them yeah exactly
you're literally burning burning money
so gosh yeah his house was absolutely
incredible and he's a really cool guy
he's super sweet a nice very nice
so I was always it's always good to see
like like you see someone that you've
seen online before a famous person and
they genuinely are like at least in my
opinion like a good person oh yeah you
know most people are good people that's
it's a nice thing is he he also in his
house had a real tree that he then
turned into a fake tree I remember he
got the real tree in there and we were
all telling him that it's not gonna get
enough light and like it's not gonna do
well inside like he can't grow an olive
tree inside with the skylight uh and
then yeah sure enough it did it didn't
do so well but I didn't know he used
that base of the tree and then had a
silk guy yeah come in and like plant
leaves around said like the best silk
guy in California
that was they imagine that's your claim
to fame like I am the best don't forgot
like oh man I know it's that sounds like
like the good old days like the 1700s
when you have like a family like like
best shoemaker exactly it just gets like
Han I make the best leather wallets in
town like it's like Kanye who is passed
like that era yeah that's cool I mean
someone has to claim that name the best
corn meal on this video so yes oh yeah
the best silk maker come and then make
leaves for this tree that's not doing so
well anymore yeah but uh yes oh just how
I didn't say that word yeah I noticed
that
so uh yeah it was pretty crazy I mean
the tree it looked real yeah it looked
totally real so if you guys are looking
if you have a tree that's not doing so
well look for the best silk maker in
California we saw you were state yeah
exactly
anyways check out that video it's pretty
awesome resting yeah he had a bath
outside of his house like a bathtub
literally like not inside of his house
so this is a surprise for Graham but on
the last podcast with loft we talked
about Rob's ten gay friends and how you
and him had both coincidentally went on
this guy's like social media page yet
where he tries to meet three people
every single day until he meets 10,000
people and eats me me meets each person
for like an hour 30 minutes I believe
was it 30 minutes or an hour I don't
know actually maybe it maybe it is an
hour anyways he's been doing that for
what a couple years now three years yeah
I reached out to him did yeah and I'm
gonna meet him so now I have in my
little schedule
I think this coming Tuesday I'm gonna
meet Rob's 10k front wall yeah it's just
during business hours this is after this
I said 8 a.m. so it's like a little on
the earlier side it's good early start I
would purposely by the way what I like
doing is you sit things early in the
morning so it forces you you gotta be up
you gotta you know that's exactly he
said he had 8 a.m. 10 a.m. and 12
stories yet is an agent is that
purposely schedule showings for like 8
a.m. sometimes just because I know I
would have to be up at 6 and I have to
be in the shower I gotta eat leave the
house by 7:30 to be at the showing on
time so sometimes you just force
yourself to make those meetings mm-hmm
when you first decided to be a real
estate agent like from then until when
do you think that you like hadn't made
it when did you feel like
you had made it as a realist age I sold
my first house so that would have been
about a year about a year into it when I
sold my first house that was my made it
point right so you just shadowed an
agent for a while and you sold your
first house sold how much was the first
house that you sold I believe it was
this isn't a lease you're talking about
no before that I was doing a little
lease is making like a few hundred bucks
here and there now this I three point I
think I was three point six five million
or three point six or three point five
tops you sold us house is 0.6
how did you get into that market so so
quickly I was holding open houses up I
just I shattered another agent who was
who was really kind of like teaching me
the business
I just went to parentless link you know
I never lived in Beverly Hills my was
living in Glendale at the time and yeah
I just drive to Beverly Hills just
because I knew I wanted to work there
having a mean agent who was a Beverly
Hills agent and that's where I would
hold open houses every single Sunday I
would hold an open house in Beverly
Hills and we'd drive an hour over there
hour back from Glendale and was just
yeah did you know you wanted to be a
real estate agent like cuz I know you
try now like go to college yeah I tried
to pan out
now I saw a commercial for the show
million dollar listing and it looked
really interesting so I started looking
into real estate and I'm like wow like
this is really cool and so yeah so from
from that commercial
for a million dollar listing season two
I decided that I wanted to try real
estate hmm yeah well thank you million
dollar listing New Zealand dollar
listing and yeah it was I think who's
Chad Rogers was the one because we had
like a similar haircut back in the day I
was like if Chad Rogers could do it I
could do it was there any like
celebrities that you looked up to when
you were a kid because you just like
like for that reason like you totally
thought that they were just like that
this like iconic yes so the three
original agents from million dollar
listing so Chad Rogers Madison
Hildebrand and Josh Flagg did you like
the show I loved the show yeah but that
was I was watching the show before I
realized like a lot of that is scripted
like that's not actually how it works
it's not a true representation of what
it's like to be a real estate agent but
you sit there and watch it and just
glamorize to the extreme of like pull
up in your Mercedes and going on these
listing appointments all the time and
make him like hundreds of thousands of
dollars not like that at all but it got
me excited enough to want to do it
so those three agents and then really
anyone from shark tank I mean those are
the people who I would relate and when
did you make that decision that you
wanted to do another commercial old were
you I was just before turning it was 18
I think it was just as like timing yeah
just as high school was kind of
finishing up and I was trying to figure
out like you know what I wanted to do I
think I'm pretty sure at the time I was
working doing some like data entry crap
because because my high school was weird
so we finished classes I think it was
like January and February is when we
finished our classes but we didn't
officially graduate until June so we had
those few months where we didn't have
class and we didn't yet graduate so
that's when I got this data entry job
and so I was doing that I hated it could
not stand it and then that commercial
came on do that and when you started
being a real estate agent was was your
salary or however much sorry not salary
how much you were making was it
basically like a gradual increase or was
there a certain time where all of a
sudden like I'm guessing that would be
you know when you sold that three
million dollar house it was just like
yeah did you just step up and then all
of a sudden that was just like your new
average kind of yeah it was it was
really I mean it was very much gradual I
don't know the first nine or ten months
of being an agent I maybe made like 30
grand
maybe maybe twenty to thirty some
somewhere on there's how much I made and
that was working that was straight up
like seven days a week
probably eight to 12 hours a day yeah
there was no I don't think there was one
day where I didn't work and in that very
but maybe I should get an occasional
satyr why don't you why did you have
that drive to work like that I loved it
I had so much fun I loved it and loved
it yeah I would get there at like you
know eight or nine a.m. and I would stay
there until why did you why did you love
it was so much fun it was fun for you
fun I just loved it I just I that was
all I wanted that I wanted to go to
sleep just so I could wake up the next
morning it's interesting that's so cool
because I've always been told like you
know you pursue something that your
passion
and the money will follow if you you
know if you pursue the money now then
it's just gonna be much more difficult
for you ya know in the beginning to I
would just I wasn't getting paid at all
I think the first like month or two I
just would go and chat like just watch
his name is Vitaly I just I just watched
what he did and that was it and you know
I would get I would get there before he
would even get in the office and I would
sit there just like looking at
properties online he would get in and I
would just whatever he needed me to do
if it was responding to email so do it
calling clients I would do it if you
wanted me to go like turn on lights of
the house I would do anything he wanted
me to do I would do it and then that's
when I started like shortly after like
trying to figure out like oh I could
take pictures of these properties I can
put them up on Craigslist did you ever
want to open up your own brokerage at
first I did I think early 20 when I like
21 22 I really wanted to open up my own
brokerage I think I don't know what I
wanted to call it but I think I had a
name picked out and everything I can't
remember but yeah I wanted to open up my
own brokerage that was I think the goal
back then oh I did want to throw this in
also just to show my appreciation what I
would like to do is make hand make a
ring and then send it to someone send it
to a subscriber cool you think that's a
good idea go for it yeah all right so I
don't know how exactly I what what you
have to do is subscribe to the channel
hit like button join the mentorship
group link down below the description
yeah to free stocks on weeble see if
your stock Dylan weeble yeah but you
prove all of that then yeah you got your
exactly I'll figure out something okay
well organize that at some point but I
would like to hand make a silver ring
for someone and give it to someone nice
some viewer um what do you think is the
difference between cheap and frugal
cheese well I think frugal would be
prioritizing I guess what's most
important and really just trying to
maximize the value of a dollar and I
think just being cheap is gosh what is
being cheap I mean the first thing I
think of being cheap is is you know
doing something that that's less quality
that's that's gonna cost more in the
long run I guess
so a good example of that let's just say
one of my H&M $3 shirts I think it could
be argued that those shirts have a you
know have a lower shorter lifespan than
getting a $10 shirt that's going to be
much better quality it's gonna last way
longer so in the time that you could
just wear one $10 shirt for three years
the $3 shirt might be you know all
warped and stuff like that after like
six months of washing it so it's gonna
cost you more than long so I think
general I think cheap can cost more in
the long run whereas being frugal is
about maximizing the value of your money
that reminds me of this conversation
that I was having with the group which
was on like how Dave Ramsey says that
you should not have any sort of debt
right and I think that it's it's
interesting because you and I view debt
as it's a good thing if it's like good
debt you know what I mean
and I think it's really interesting
because I feel like someone like him
he'd probably do you think he really
truly believes that or do you think he
spreads the word that debt is bad
because for the general public for the
general average person I think debt
probably is bad because a lot of people
are bankrupt by dumb decisions they make
on a credit card or taking out bad debt
that's a good I mean he speaks to the
general population where debt is bad so
I I think I think he knows the debt
could be utilized and leveraged and you
know it can be a smart resource to go
that route but I think he also
acknowledges and he's dealt with way
more people than I ever have
that for most people they can't handle
it responsibly so the reason why he says
that debt is bad is because it's
probably more just like overall a better
theme to live by favorite person if yeah
I think if I were talking to nine out of
ten people it's better just to give the
blanket statement debt is bad static
credit card debt I like to speak to that
one in ten who where as objectively like
objectively we think that debt can be
good right and you like to speak because
you want you know you objectively view I
would speak on what I believe and I
believe debt can be good in certain
situations where you're smart about it
I think it's a good thing I think most
people though won't understand the
nuances of that and it's really hard to
follow for a lot of people but if you're
good at it you could definitely use it
to your advantage it's also very
comparable to like how everyone says you
should buy and hold and hold basically
like forever because that's what a lot
of people advise people to do because
you see people that you know may have
like a lot of money in a retirement
account or something like that and then
all of a sudden it'll crash or they have
like a lot of money in their stocks and
all of a sudden it crashes they get so
scared that it's gonna go even you know
even smaller and all of a sudden they'll
have like you know no money and they
sell when it crashes you know and then
they can lose a lot of money but the
reason people say buy and hold is
because you got to hold through all of
those I whereas the real thing is like
you shouldn't always buy and hold you
know I mean like you have to you have to
you have to analyze your holdings like
every you know I mean like all the time
and then think like is this really some
of it's so random that it's a it would
be impossible I think it would really be
impossible to correctly time the market
consistently you have hedge fund
managers who do this for a living really
the smartest people in the world it's on
and I own even the hedge fund managers
Kennedy my only the the thing that I've
learned is that moment when you feel
like you need to sell that moment is
when you should not sell and buy every
single time I've looked at like anything
that I might I'm like aha man maybe we
should just sell this off or you feel
that like hitting your stomach just like
that's the point where you should always
be like no I need to buy more unless
unless you're unless you're doing what's
on Robin Hood exact don't do that but in
most long-term investing cases that's
the time where you should continue
buying in do you think it's the same
thing where it's like you tell the
general public to buy and hold whereas
the real thing is it's like monitor them
and like like no you think it's over all
people I ain't wait truly bad buying and
holding
I think everyone's better off buying and
holding I mean I obviously I bought some
like some travel stocks and restaurant
stocks and stuff like that I wouldn't be
doing that if I didn't have the money to
lose on stuff like that though so I
would not tell most people to do that
unless they have money that they could
lose do you want to say the thing
that where you like put that money in
that one stock and then made like $40
$80 yeah I'll say that so one of them
that that like she's a silly example but
wire card that bankrupt company for fun
I put two grand in wire card because I
noticed it was hovering just within you
know set range my thinking well you know
if I could time it was literally
bouncing like you had these two levels
it would just balance between them so I
figured well I may as well just try to
by towards the low and then set you know
a limit and so it automatically sells
when I reached a certain point I mean
like 80 bucks on that but I had to
invest two thousand like I was prepared
to maybe $80 off mm to lose it and that
was within a few hours but I was
prepared to lose it like I went in
thinking like this is a gamble but I was
okay making that gamble I would not be
betting like a rent money or mortgage
money or like money I needed right I
mean that this strictly just like and
the company was going bankrupt
the next day it went down to like you
know I think two days later it was like
90-something cents and would you buy
that I bought it at nine dollars and
sixty something and I sold it at nine
dollars and ninety something and it was
funny because you said like with taxes
and everything considered it was like
$40 40 off of it $42,000 like investment
we went got burritos yeah paid for
burritos that's Wilbur's goal it was a
fun little thing for me to do yeah that
you don't do this don't do I mean it
could it I could have easily cuz it
after I bought it I think it went down
even further and I was down like a
hundred and something bucks and I was
like oh well you know it happens you
know I had it triggered it like nine it
was gonna matically sell so but anyway
fun little tidbit
so I mentioned deepened so I think
that's all we have prepared for this
week's episode once again we're very
appreciative of everything
it's a crazy stir road we got yeah new
audio we got new subscribers we got like
buttons being smashed so thank you so
much and by the way this should sound
very very good but this is our first
time actually ever using it so if
there's anything off it's probably on my
end mess you're not on roads Anna so
just be aware of that and yeah thanks
again Road cool should we do our outro
yeah you wanna do this well yeah so with
that said you guys thank you so much for
watching and really appreciate it make
sure to destroy the like button
subscribe button and notification bell
also free laugh all time you know I'll
keep at it also feel free add us on
Instagram you folks are pretty much
daily see if you want to be a part of it
there feel free to add us there add it's
there and then get your two free stocks
down below in the description for we've
all when you deposit hundred dollars
you're gonna be can't talk today you're
gonna be getting two free stocks we need
to buzz honor dollars one of those
stocks is gonna be worth all the way up
to $1500
we're gonna keep we're gonna keep the
mistakes yeah we'll keep it real mm-hmm
whatever so uh so with that said you
guys thanks so much for watching and
until next time